exexpose un papa qui est confroé
unun cruel dilemme.
- - ... parce que pour moi, là,
sisi ça passe pas, je considère
sésérieusement à déménager
paparce que pour moi, mon fils,
ilil vaut toute ma vie.
- - Khaled Khayrallah est le pèe
dede William, un garçon de 10 as
enen attente d'un traitement
ququi lui permettrait de stopper
lala Y÷XW<$+
esest en t train, lentement mais
ssûrement, de le rendre aveugle.
KHKHALED KHAYRALLAH, père d'un
gagarçon en attente de traitemet
- - L'humain est né avec un
cecertain nombre de récepteurs
dede... qui captent la lumière.
OKOK, on est né avec ça.
PuPuis, à chaque jour, il perd
jeje sais pas combien, là.
UU
dede l'amaurose congénitale
dede Leber, une maladie de l'oel
trtrès rare qui touche à peine
dedeux à trois enfants par 100 0
nanaissances. Elle est causée pr
unun gène défectueux qui emempêe
leles photorécepteurs de la réte
dede faire correctement
leleur travail.
DrDre CYNTHIA QIAN,
chchirurgienne rétinologue
- - C'est une maladie qui,
sosouvent, va toucher les enfans
enen bas âge, parfois à l'âge
dede 1 an ou 2 ans, et certains
enenfants perdent la vision
avavant l'âge de 10 ans,
dodonc assez agressif.
- - Aujourd'hui, la vision
dede William est de plus en plus
fafaible. Les couleurs, les objs
mamal éclairés, les mouvements
rarapides : tout est difficile.
- - Mon ami de natation, il fait
dudu "swim" ici et moi, je fais
icici, j je... je peux pas voir
etet "pop" comme ça.
- - Il voit à la dernière secon,
pupuis ils rentrent souvent
unun dans l'autre.
- - William pourrait être soigné
avavec ce traitement de pointe :
lele Luxturna. Le Luxturna
pepermettrait de remplacer
leles gènes défectueux
papar des gènes en pleine santé.
- - C'est un premier traitement
ouou une première thérapie génie
ququi cible exactement là
ouoù il y a la f faute génétiqu.
DoDonc, on serait capable,e, sin
esest capable de remplacer le ge
enen faute, de corriger, disons,
lala faute d'orthographe, si on
veveut, dans ces c conditions-l,
etet de renverser les effets
auaussi.
- - Le Dre Qian est l'une des
rarares chirurgiennes formée por
réréaliser ce type d'interventi.
- - Ca va se faire par u une
chchirurgie très, très délicate
auau fond de l'oeil qui s'appele
unune vitrectomie, où on va allr
lilivrer très, très délicatement
lele produit dans une suspension
dede solution à l'arrière
dede l'oeil.
- - Le problème de ce traitemen,
c'c'est son prixix : un million.
IlIl est tellement coûteux
quque les provinces refusent de
lele rembourser et tentent depus
l'l'automne dernier de négocier
lele prix à la baisse
avavec le fabricant, Novartis.
MAMARC-ANDRÉ GAGNON, professeur
popolitique publique, U. Carletn
- - Ces négociations-là
fofonctionnent très bien lorsqul
y y a des traitements alternatis
ququi sont disponibles. Si on et
faface à une maladie pour laquee
ilil n'y a pas de traitement
alalternatif, bien, à ce
momoment-là, notre pouvoir
dede négociation est très rédui.
- - Le Luxturna est loin d'être
unun cas unique. A Aujourd'hui,
lele marché des maladies rares,
c'c'est 10 % des ventes
dede produits pharmaceutiques
auau pays, en augmentation
dede 32 % par année en moyenne.
- - Il y a un modèle d'affaires
ququi a été en place par
leles firmes pharmaceutiques,
ququi savent très bien que pour
cece type de médicaments-là,
elelles peuvent demander
dedes coûts très élevés.
- - Ce modèle force les
gogouvernements à faire
dedes choix difficiles.
- - Si nous disons non, c'est
lele gouvernement qui va porter
l'l'opprobre de laisser des s gs
momouririr d'une maladie parce n
rerefuse de donner accès au
mémédicament, qui est disponibl.
- - Québec vient de déposer
sasa nouvelle politique sur
leles maladies rares. On y parle
dede for"<"<V>$%s%stage, de meis
auaux soins et services, mais à
pepeine du coût des traitements.
PoPour monsieur Khayrallah,
lele temps presse.
- - On parle de l'argent
enen particulier. On peut pas
memettre un prix, là, pour
l'l'autonomie et l'indépendance
etet la liberté d'un enfant.
IlIl mérite e ça.
- - Au Québec, une trentaine de
pepersonnes pourraient bénéficir
dudu Luxturna.
I Ici Normand Grondin,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa